Transcription: Alessandra Mero
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir, je suis ravie
d’être parmi vous ce soir.
Je suis Drifa Choulet.
Mon métier, c’est d’accompagner
les managers, les dirigeants
et de les aider à réfléchir.
Avant cela,
j’ai passé 20 ans dans la finance.
Alors, on me demande souvent :
« Mais Drifa, quel lien est-ce que tu fais
entre ces deux métiers,
le coaching aujourd’hui,
la finance hier ? »
Je vous l’accorde,
ce lien n’est pas forcément évident.
Il y en a un, pourtant,
c’est celui des relations humaines.
Ça tombe bien puisque c’est de ça
dont je vais vous parler ce soir.
C’est ce que Charlotte présentait,
c’est le thème de ce TED ce soir.
« L’enfer, c’est les autres. »
Vous connaissez sûrement
cette phrase de Jean-Paul Sartre.
Peut-être qu’elle vous traverse l’esprit
de temps à autre.
Savez-vous pourtant qu’au-delà de ce
que veulent dire ces mots littéralement,
« L’enfer, c’est les autres »,
ce que Sartre cherchait à nous dire,
c’est précisément l’inverse ?
Ce que Sartre voulait dire,
c’est que l’autre,
cet autre moi, ce miroir de nous-mêmes
nous offre la possibilité de faire
un apprentissage extraordinaire sur nous,
qui est d’acquérir
cette conscience de nous.
Cette conscience de nous
qui est l’une des manières de développer
notre intelligence émotionnelle.
C’est ainsi que l’on grandit,
que l’on se développe.
Je voudrais vous parler des relations
humaines sous un axe particulier
qui est celui du monde professionnel.
Je voudrais vous raconter une anecdote
qui date d’un des derniers confinements
qu’on a vécus.
Ce jour-là, j’avais une séance
de coaching à distance.
Et au début de cette séance,
ma cliente me dit :
« Vous savez, Drifa, je me suis rarement
sentie aussi seule de ma vie
et je ne comprends pas.
Je ne vis pas seule, j'ai un mari,
des enfants, un travail.
Tout se passe bien
et pourtant je me sens seule. »
Ce jour-là, nous n’avons pas travaillé
sur le sujet
pour lequel je l’accompagnais.
Nous avons plutôt cherché à éclairer,
à mettre en lumière
ce sentiment de solitude.
Ce qui en est ressorti,
c’est que cette femme passait
8 à 10 heures par jour
depuis de longs mois sur un écran.
Ce que vous avez vous-même vécu sans
doute, qui avez été en cours à distance,
c’est que passer 8 à 10 heures par jour
de cette manière,
en interaction mais à distance,
avait généré ce sentiment de solitude.
Alors oui, le télétravail,
les cours à distance, ont eu un impact
sur nos relations humaines.
Elles se sont virtualisées,
de ce fait déshumanisées.
Mais le terme que j’utilise souvent,
c’est que nos échanges sont devenus
ces deux dernières années,
transactionnels, utilitaristes.
Je vais vous illustrer ça
par deux exemples.
Dans la vraie vie, quand on va travailler
ou quand on va en cours,
comment ça se passe ? On arrive le matin,
on salue nos collègues,
on va prendre un café ensemble
et puis on échange.
« Tiens, j’ai vu un film sympa hier. »
« Je pars en vacances bientôt.
Le Pays basque, vous avez
des conseils à me donner ? »
Quelqu’un dit :
« Au fait, Anna, ce dossier Baron,
est-ce qu’on pourrait se voir à 11 h
pour en parler ? »
Quand on est à distance,
comment ça se passe ?
À 9 h, on allume son ordinateur.
On a peut-être encore un bas
de pyjama ou des chaussons.
Un message arrive à 9 h 05 :
« Anna, on se fait une visio à 11 h
pour parler du dossier Baron ? »
À 11 h, ladite Anna se connecte.
« Attends, je te partage mon écran.
Tu vois ces deux slides-là ?
« Est-ce que tu pourrais me les compléter
et me les envoyer pour 13 h ? »
C’est ainsi que naît
ce sentiment de solitude.
La séance de coaching dont je vous parlais
a été pour moi l’une des histoires,
l’une des séances les plus marquantes
de ces dernières années.
Elle a probablement résonné
comme elle résonne peut-être chez vous.
Elle a mis en lumière le fait que quand
nos relations basculent soudainement,
durablement dans un monde virtuel,
le sentiment de solitude émerge.
On parle beaucoup aujourd’hui
du metaverse.
Je suis sûre que
vous en avez entendu parler.
Ce monde, un peu de science-fiction,
où nous serions équipés
de casques de réalité virtuelle et où
nous pourrions, sans quitter notre salon,
aller gravir le Machu Picchu,
surfer à Hawaï, faire le tour du monde.
La question qu’on peut se poser,
c’est : à ce moment-là
serons-nous encore en relation ?
Ou est-ce qu’on évoluera simplement
les uns à côté des autres ?
Le fait est que les relations humaines
datent de la nuit des temps,
j’ai envie de dire,
depuis nos ancêtres préhistoriques,
qui allaient en groupe
à chasser le mammouth pour leur famille.
Ils nous ont laissé collectivement
des merveilleuses traces
dans des endroits comme Lascaux,
et se sont établis progressivement
en campement, en village, en ville,
jusqu’à notre civilisation,
ici, ce soir.
De nombreuses études
ont été menées sur le sujet.
La plus longue étude menée sur l’impact
des relations sociales sur le bonheur
a été faite à Harvard.
Elle s'est déroulée sur plus de 75 ans.
Ce que cette étude a montré,
c’est que les personnes
qui vivaient les plus heureuses
étaient celles qui avaient
tout au long de leur vie
des relations sociales et humaines
de qualité.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez entendu parler
du grand psychologue Abraham Maslow
qui, lui, a théorisé
les choses d’une autre manière.
Il a théorisé les besoins fondamentaux
de l'être humain.
Ses travaux ont été adaptés
en une pyramide,
la pyramide de Maslow
que vous voyez à l’écran.
Cette pyramide illustre aussi
remarquablement le fait que,
une fois satisfaits
nos besoins fondamentaux,
que sont les besoins physiologiques -
se nourrir, boire, se vêtir -
nos besoins de sécurité,
le troisième besoin fondamental
de l’homme, de chacun d’entre nous,
c’est le besoin d’appartenance.
C’est le besoin de lien, d’appartenance
à un groupe, d’amour, d’amitié.
Je voudrais vous proposer
un petit sondage à main levée,
pour revenir dans le monde professionnel.
Qui parmi vous, ce soir,
pense qu’il est essentiel
d’avoir de bonnes relations
dans le monde du travail ?
OK, merci.
Qui parmi vous, il y en a peut-être,
pense qu’en fait tout cela n’a pas
finalement grande importance
et que ce qui compte,
c’est juste faire son job.
Merci beaucoup. (Rit.)
Vos réactions ce soir,
ce que je constate de vos mains
illustrent complètement le fait que,
comme l’a montré une recherche
d’un institut sur le leadership
et le management,
97 % des personnes pensent effectivement
qu’avoir de bonnes relations au travail
est quelque chose d’essentiel.
Vous qui êtes là ce soir,
majoritairement étudiants,
certains parmi vous qui commencez
à toucher à la vie active,
que ce soit par vos stages,
vos alternances, vos vies associatives,
sachez que dans le monde de l’entreprise,
du travail au sens large,
d’un grand groupe aux startups,
un commerce ou une usine,
le travail est ce lieu où l’apprentissage
de la relation humaine
se fait de manière continue.
C’est ce lieu où l’on doit entrer
en relation avec des personnes
que l’on n’a pas choisies,
contrairement à nos amis par exemple.
Ce que l’on va attendre de vous,
de nous dans ce monde,
ce sont non seulement des compétences
que vous avez apprises à l’école
ou que vous apprenez à l’école -
la finance, le marketing, la logistique,
je pourrais citer d’autres - mais
ce que l’on va surtout attendre de vous
et de manière croissante
après cette pandémie,
ce sont des savoir-être,
ces fameuses soft skills
dont la qualité relationnelle,
la capacité à nouer des relations
est la plus importante.
Elle est importante, pourquoi ?
Elle est importante d’abord pour vous,
pour votre motivation
et pour le sens
que vous trouverez au travail.
Elle est également importante,
le jour où vous souhaiterez, peut-être,
devenir manager, leader,
pour entraîner les autres.
Vous ne réussirez à le faire
que parce que vous aurez réussi à nouer
cette relation avec vos collaborateurs,
votre équipe, vos collègues, vos managers.
À ce stade, vous vous dites:
« Bon ok, tout cela est bien beau.
N’est-ce pas un peu utopique ?
Est-ce qu’on peut réellement
s’entendre avec tout le monde ? »
Vous avez raison
de vous poser la question.
Mais là n’est pas justement
le point en fait.
Il y a une petite subtilité là-dedans.
Non, effectivement, il n’est pas possible,
probablement, de s’entendre avec tous.
Ce dont il s’agit là,
c’est de se dire : comment nouer
des relations professionnelles de qualité
avec tout le monde,
que l’on s’entende finalement ou pas
avec la personne ?
Je suis convaincue que c’est possible et
je voudrais partager avec vous trois idées
que vous pourriez mettre en œuvre
assez vite, je l’espère, pour tester cela.
La première de ces idées, c'est l'écoute.
On n'écoute pas assez.
Repensez à la manière dont
un échange peut se dérouler.
On peut avoir assez vite tendance
à penser à la question qu’on va poser
juste après ou se dire :
« Ah tiens, il faut que je dise ça. »
Écouter, c’est écouter
évidemment les mots.
Ils sont importants, ils sont
la première chose que l’on exprime.
Sachez toutefois que
les mots ne représentent que 7%
de ce que l’on dit dans un échange.
Ça peut paraître surprenant :
93% de ce que l’on exprime
se fait en dehors des mots,
se fait par notre attitude corporelle,
se fait par le ton de notre voix.
Donc, je vous invite
lorsque vous êtes en interaction
et pour que cette interaction soit
profitable, bénéfique, positive,
à écouter au-delà des mots.
Le deuxième conseil
que je voudrais vous donner,
qui est un peu le corollaire de l’écoute,
c’est le questionnement.
Plus on grandit, plus on perd
cette capacité à questionner.
Certaines recherches ont montré
que les enfants questionnent
70 à 75% du temps, finalement.
Quand on est devenu adulte,
cette proportion passe à moins d’un quart.
La raison pour ça, elle est principalement
dans notre éducation d’abord,
puisqu’on est, et pas seulement en France,
dans une éducation qui valorise
le fait d’apporter des réponses.
On répond à des examens,
on répond à des évaluations.
Au travail, on va attendre de nous
qu’on résolve des problèmes,
qu’on apporte des réponses.
Or questionner, là encore, c’est un signe
d’ouverture extraordinaire à l’autre.
N’hésitez pas à ouvrir la discussion
et à poser des questions.
Le troisième élément, c’est simplement
de ne pas chercher à changer l’autre,
de ne pas forcément chercher à
penser à la place de l’autre non plus.
C’est d’aller chercher dans nos
complémentarités, dans nos différences,
ce point d’équilibre qui va nous permettre
d’établir une relation gagnant-gagnant.
Pour finir, je voudrais vous laisser avec
cette phrase d’Antoine de Saint-Exupéry
que j’aime beaucoup, qui disait :
« La grandeur d’un métier est peut-être,
avant tout, d’unir les hommes :
il n’est qu’un seul luxe véritable,
c’est celui des relations humaines. »
Merci de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)